for me the only way to do that is to
talk about my life and the things that
grow along with me the only thing that
grows along with me my experiences my
family my marriage my mistakes my UPS my
downs those are the things that I can
talk about father because as you get
older things change shit gets different
it's all coming from my personal opinion
of me my view on me and how I see life
you can't lose material in that state
mm-hmm that's why I stay away from
certain things because those things can
become boring after a while for me
because I don't have the knowledge of
everything that I should like what well
politics I don't know joke in the
politics I don't I don't joke and
anything that has to do with the slander
of others or other communities I don't
do anything divisive good for you that's
my that's my biggest thing and you know
this past year was was one that got a
little weird because I was like you know
I've really dedicated myself to breaking
people together like I'm I know that was
my my goal that's what my priority I
damn sure thought that's what I was
doing on a global scale everybody all
races shapes sizes whoever you are
whatever you are you can come to a Kevin
Hart show and have a good time so when
it came off as if I was a person that
was divisive
that was tough you talking about the
Oscar Oscar shit yeah this is a time
where people are just looking to be
upset about things a hundred they're
they're not looking to looking at you
Kevin Hart is just a human being like
what who is he who overall super
positive they're not even concentrating
on that I mean think about how positive
you are and yet they tried to
concentrate on some jokes that you did
what nine years ago it was a it's a it's
a wake up call of understanding the
times but it more importantly you know
for me it was okay I went through it I
made sure that the people of the LGBTQ
community really understand it hey guys
I apologized before but I'm apologizing
again I'm sorry
I'm not that guy I don't want you to
think I'm that guy then it just became
the constant conversation there never
happened that it just became the
constant conversation and and now it is
guys I'm not only sorry I don't condone
anything that has to do with hate to
anybody this is no longer conversation
so guys I'm gonna stop talking about it
because now I feel like I'm feeding into
yes what I'm not I I know I'm not the
world and public should understand and
no to them not because over this time
period I've shown that I'm not so the
apology once again I'm sorry
genuinely I'm sorry but then it just
kept it just it never stopped and at
that point I just made a decision and
I'm like guys at this point I just I'm
making a decision to not talk about it
anymore
that doesn't mean that I'm being
disrespectful to anybody that doesn't
mean I'm shutting down anything it means
that for me I'm gonna stop talking about
it because at this point I don't know
what to do at this point I thought I
thought the apology is what you want me
to do I did it I made sure that you
understand that I'm not a hateful person
I don't get don't hate I did that I
stepped down so I don't take attention
off of that night and those people that
are there to be celebrated I don't want
to draw attention to myself and what's
around me I step down everything I did
was for the better of good I'm stepping
away guys because I don't want this to
be a negative night or a negative thing
and then it still became a conversation
so I waited for it to die down I went on
my radio show
I gave another public apology make sure
he understand it I'm sorry
I hope these words didn't hurt anybody I
once again apologized I don't condone
hate to anyone I hope that you guys can
forgive me for those josepho so now I
say if you don't understand that you
don't believe it I don't know what else
to give I don't know what else to do
there's nothing else you can do that's
very wise of you not
that's very wise easy to step away like
that because if you didn't they would
probably pursue it forever I mean it's
it becomes a point of attention that's
all it is it's decided that this is
something they're gonna focus on what I
had a I had a good talk and I'm gonna
talk about this for a minute friend of
mine Lee Daniels you know man Lee
Daniels Lee called me told me where to
talk to you know Lee Daniels is director
producer the show empires you know his
biggest shows you know so he calls me
he's like everyone talk to you and and I
was talking he's like look this is a
time where you could speak up and talk
about you know the community that's been
affected by hatred and you know hateful
crimes you can step up and be a voice
and say that you don't condone or don't
stand with any type of hate or whatever
you can take that stage and do that and
I said Lee I said that's I understand
what you're saying I said well why did
you expect me to know what's been
happening with in this community in
regards to hate and crimes I said I I'm
not aware I said some people can just
not be aware I'm not even know I have no
idea what's going on I have no idea yes
within that community I have no idea
right when you tell me this I'm now
educated and I understand so it's easy
to simply inform right information is
key when people get information they
process the information when you can
process the information you go oh wait a
minute that makes sense
hey if you guys think that I can don't
hate wait a minute I don't in anybody
that does fuck you man that's bad you
shouldn't I can say that but instead
when this happened it was becoming a lie
mmm become a voice you know and that's
that's where there was just a
miscommunication that's where a back and
worth kind of was established that I
think people just started to take things
and run with it and I'm just not I'm
just not one to feed into what I feel
isn't going to eventually evolve into a
positive thing in a real conversation
yes yeah when I'm trying my best to it
was becoming tabloid bullshit opposed to
like a real discussion click me yeah
click click me